i figured out teleportation too wait
what that would help swear to god wait
first of all who are we going to shrink
first we'll start with the blacks maybe
the
okay but no what about teleportation
[Laughter]
i figured out a lot of [__] okay give me
teleportation
man i'm uh
my mind is racing right now i could talk
about a bunch of abstract thoughts go
this is what we like here yeah all right
all right we get in the weed or what
yo you give me the weed i'll be [__]
flying
no no but you figured out teleportation
i want to hear this i i really think i
have this has dust on it too
no no not that type of dust
[Laughter]
again no because not wait hold on let me
let me explain this foundation go go go
go because also dog i'm not smoking this
if you don't smoke it all right
let's [__] go just one week
every time we got enough
i've never smoked online they've never
seen you really they've seen me high
they know she'd be smoking this is your
elon moment things worked out for him
afterwards i love you so i'll do it here
[__] it but okay teleportation all right
there's gonna be a point i believe where
uh human beings will be able to
this is i'm sorry but it will happen
upload their consciousness yeah on to x
i don't know what it is blockchain
internet what the [__] you wanna call it
everything that doesn't exist yet
the consciousness will have the ability
to learn grow and adapt based on past
learnings growings and adaptations
because of ai artificial intelligence
machines learning how
to learn
cloning also illegal now but cloning for
humans for humans that you could clone a
[__] dog in korea you know that i bet
they love that i bet that
i don't know [__] kfc
[Laughter]
cloning is a very real technology that
already that already exists we just
choose to not clone humans because it's
[__] up but people have done it with
their dogs and ellen cloned her dog
what yeah you know this she cloned her
dog her dog passed and then she cleaned
it they cloned a sheep in scotland yeah
yeah yeah okay so that technology exists
also the uploading of your consciousness
will exist fact
will exist they've started this you know
that not consciousness but they've like
created um
they use like someone's social media a
guy whose wife passed they use her
social media to create like a version of
who she would be online yeah yeah also
is that it right here it was barbra
streisand clone the dog yeah no look at
ellen's dog too
maybe because they're clones they both
get up okay okay so eventually
i need to iron this out before i pitch
it in my presidential campaign but yeah
eventually when he would find a morally
sound way to clone
their flesh puppet
this will only be available to like
upper-class people who have the means to
uh holy [__] to do clone yourself you
upload your consciousness somewhere
re-download it you grow up and then you
download the consciousness back to you
you don't have to grow your your your
body would be in parts of the world that
you visit frequently right so i could
get through i could get to france right
now
stop and you you oh
[__] it's a dropbox it's dropbox
you've got ten bodies everywhere bingo
hey i live in miami as well when i want
and i'm in this hyperbaric chamber and
when i want to be there i'm [__]
there you go you station your body and
you're constantly you can clone it but
also modify it if you want to you can go
in miami you could have like a cuban
shirt what are we even talking about
mm-hmm or coveted yeah
okay this is interesting you have a
japanese schultz i wanted you to have
yours
no you can't why not why not you can
edit it gene editing
what do you speak japanese or be
japanese well i have to i'm talking
about clone yeah
yeah so he shows but he's cloned and
then you gene splice no because because
when you up when you
it would have to work like this when you
upload your consciousness and it it
beams to your next body
the one that it came from needs to be
the exact same no no it needs to like
turn off yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't
have two operating at the same time you
can't [__] everything up
and you know what
we won't be able to do it wait but you
could download someone into someone
else's little flashlight right
essentially call them sleep so like you
go you go to europe to be honest you're
that logan paul that could re-download
into your body and then murder somebody
in his [__] body bingo we just made
the best horror movie ever it's actually
why would you murder i wouldn't murder
no but it'll happen this is where things
get tricky and why this probably will
never happen but i figured it out like
we don't need to worry about it